the movie opens up at Stratford
University where we are introduced to
the main character Daryl Witherspoon
Daryl is a helpful guy and he's
assisting a group of students on a
University tour but to everyone's
surprise while giving the tour he's also
working as a mailman doing two jobs at
once Daryl takes the students around the
university and all the while he's
completing his mailman duties after
finishing one tour he immediately starts
another with a new group of students in
the next scene we see Daryl in his room
taking a nap with the TV playing in the
background right then his mom calls
abruptly waking him up she inquires
about his job prospects and Daryl tells
her that he's the top Contender for a
great job however in reality he is badly
struggling with finances after some time
the University's tuition office calls
him asking about his semester fee
payment but since Daryl doesn't have any
money to pay he pretends to be someone
else and claims that Daryl got killed
later A desperate Daryl gets creative
and tries various ways to earn extra
cash he goes to a blood bank and donates
a lot of blood but ends up passing out
he then goes to a sperm bank to donate
sperm but that also leaves him exhausted
moving on Daryl's determination to make
money leads him to a hair braiding salon
where he wants to donate his hair but
since he has short hair he wants to
donate something else from his lower
body as expected this enrages the owner
and he is promptly kicked out well no
pube transplants for you the next day at
the University cafeteria Daryl is
approached by his classmate Scott the
latter is also a candidate for the job
Daryl has applied to and both appear to
be Rivals to make fun of each other and
explain why they are better suited for
the job meanwhile a beautiful girl named
Janice enters the cafeteria and Daryl is
instantly captivated by her locks later
at class A representative from
smythe-based Corporation comes as a
guest lecturer to talk about the job
they're offering he explains the
qualifications required for the job
emphasizing the importance of being
active in sports and social activities
he also mentions that the winner will be
selected from the five finalists
unfortunately Scott seems to have all
the qualifications required for the
prestigious job which worries Daryl
however he doesn't give up and decides
to Showcase his athleticism by playing
ice hockey Daryl approaches his coach
even though he has never played hockey
before the coach initially says no but
Daryl is determined to prove himself he
then turns to his roommate Tim who is
the hockey team captain and asks for his
help in convincing the coach eventually
Daryl gets a chance to play as a stopper
but he struggles and gets hit by the
puck multiple times failing to save any
goals classic comedy scene I wonder if
he also farted one day while cleaning
the campus Daryl discovers a pamphlet
about a neuropsychology seminar that
promises to pay participants seeing an
opportunity to earn some extra dough he
attends the seminar there they talk
about a new drug that can heighten human
senses to a whole new level however as
they explain the side effects many
students start leaving the workshop and
Daryl falls asleep after the
presentation Daryl finds himself alone
in the room and unbeknownst to the side
effects of the drug he agrees to take
the test just for the sake of earning
some Skrill Daryl then meets Dr Thomas
Whedon who explains that he needs to
inject six dosages of the the drug into
his buttocks every night before bedtime
Dr Whedon also warns Daryl about
possible disorientation and side effects
he might experience in the initial usage
of the drug later in the evening Daryl
attends a fraternity party with the hope
of making new friends there he comes
across Janus once again and gathers the
courage to ask her out surprisingly she
agrees to go out with him which makes
Daryl happy however his Joy is
short-lived when Scott arrives there and
insults him in front of everyone feeling
hurt and left out Daryl decides to leave
the party once he reaches home he
decides to take the first dosage of the
drug as suggested by the doctor let me
just stick this in my ass real quick the
following day during an examine
Professor engel's class Daryl starts
experiencing the drug side effects in an
intense way his senses have become extra
sensitive as the ordinary sounds like
pencil's writing or watches ticking
start to bother him even the lights
reflecting off a classmate's diamond
necklace on settle him after a while
Daryl becomes visibly uncomfortable and
his facial expressions and Body Language
change drastically when the professor
asks him to stop Daryl feels even more
frustrated and goes straight to Dr
whedon's office with complaints
fortunately the latter reassures him
that the drug is working as intended and
the discomfort he's experiencing is just
a part of the experiment the doctor then
advises Daryl to exercise his senses to
gain control over them and live a normal
life taking this advice to Heart Daryl
tries very hard and eventually manages
to take control of his senses it
actually develops heightened senses
giving him a kind of superpower as Daryl
continues his daily routine he works as
a kitchen staff for the University's
program trying to make ends meet
meanwhile the smith-based corporation is
celebrating with their finalists for the
job competition even though Daryl didn't
make it to the finals he used his new
superpower of Senses to impress the
panelists this unexpected display of
Daryl's abilities persuades the
panelists to make him the sixth finalist
for the job competition why don't you
just tell us you were taking steroids
nice later that night while celebrating
his success of selection Daryl sees
Janice entering a restroom with her
friend using his super hearing he
eavesdrops on their conversation and
learns that Janice is looking for a guy
who is intelligent caring and smart also
probably looks like Chris Hemsworth and
has three million dollars a year
encouraged by this knowledge Daryl
decides to take his chance and
approaches Janus as soon as she walks
out of the restroom using his sense of
smell he gets closer to her and exactly
guesses the perfume she has been wearing
how does Super smell give you knowledge
of perfume Brands you might wonder well
I don't know this impresses Janice and
she asks if he would like to have dinner
with her she even kisses him on the
cheeks making him blush the next day Tim
spots Daryl using injections on his
buttocks and deduces that he has become
addicted to drugs later in college Daryl
impresses the hockey coach with his
skillful skating and even saves a puck
flying towards them preventing an
accident as a result he is allowed to
join the team taking full advantage of
this opportunity Derek excels in the
game saving every goal even Scott is
left in awe of his performance the scene
then shifts to an inter-college ice
hockey match and the commentators
mentioned that Stratford University has
a terrible history with the game but
this time they have no idea that Daryl
is playing as the goalie his team takes
an early lead and he manages to stop
virtually everything thrown at him in
the end Stratford wins a game for the
first time ever and everyone celebrates
the success next Daryl goes for an
interview at the smith-based corporation
office using his superpower he listens
to the questions being asked in the
interview Daryl then fills in the
information that other interviewees had
missed earlier during his own interview
with this he impresses Randall Tyson one
of the board members who wants Daryl to
impress Arlo Vickers a potential client
of their company our boy agrees to do
this right away Tyson then informs Daryl
that the final decision will be made
within five days that night Daryl
invites Janice for dinner and Cooks
delicious meals for her later the duo
enjoys the food and each other's company
during the conversation Daryl impresses
Janice by dedicating beautiful and
romantic lines for her from a poem that
his roommate came is Reading in the
other room surprisingly this excites her
so much that she kisses him they then
end up having intercourse but Daryl
ejaculates prematurely a problem that
disappoints Janice and prompts her to
leave the next day Daryl surprises his
family by bringing Janice along and
introducing her to everyone his mother
Praises his friendly Behavior to Janus
while Daryl talks with his siblings
before leaving Daryl gives some money to
his mother to help her with household
expenses making her emotion back in the
dorm Tim finds Daryl using the drug
again and becomes concerned about him
this time he inquires about it to Daryl
and the latter tries to explain the
positive results he's experiencing
however Tim does not believe in him and
assumes that Daryl has become addicted
to drugs desperate to prove that he is
not an addict and that it has only
positive results Daryl takes a double
dose of the drug now he'll ejaculate
without even touching his belt the next
day because of the overdose he wakes up
feeling numb in his arms and legs making
it difficult for him to walk seeing his
friend in such a condition Tim
immediately calls a drug support group
for help meanwhile Daryl somehow manages
to reach Dr whedon's clinic and tells
him about exceeding the dosage the
doctor explains that the double dose has
caused a serotonin boost desensitizing
his receptors he then mentions that now
only four of his senses can work at a
time constantly switching the fifth one
this means at any given point he will
either be blind or deaf or mute and so
on Dr Whedon explains that the only
solution to this problem is to wait for
the drug to leave his system by his
calculation it will take three days so
until then Daryl will have to stay in
bed however the latter cannot waste even
a single day as he has a final
competition coming up for the job the
scene shifts to a basketball match where
Daryl sits with the board member Tyson
soon the special guest Vickers also
arrives to inspect Daryl's main task is
to impress him with his skills however
just after a few moments he starts
feeling uncomfortable his senses play
tricks on him he mistakes people
standing up for the national anthem as
an opportunity to get beers his eyes get
blurry and he even talks to himself
Vickers finds this amusing and laughs at
Daryl's odd behavior though his eyesight
returns after a while Daryl's troubles
are far from over during the game a
player throws him to the court for
insulting him and the meeting with
Vickers doesn't go as planned but
despite the situation Tyson informs
Daryl that they are good as they still
have a chance to woo Vickers later at
night in the dorm Tim sees a girl
Lorraine entering their room and rushes
to inform the drug support group
thinking it's another potential problem
with Daryl's medicine usage Lorraine who
is actually Genesis sister flirts with
Daryl but his senses are still off and
he can't hear her properly just as his
hearing returns Lorraine starts to kiss
him but Daryl can't feel anything due to
the numbing effect of the drug when he
fails to perform Lorraine gets
disappointed and leaves unfortunately at
the same time Janice arrives there and
notices her sister she then enters
Daryl's room and finds him in an awkward
position lying naked on the floor this
makes Janice upset and she walks away
but not before kicking Daryl's eggplant
soon the support group arrives but when
they enter Daryl's room they find that
he is already passed out and consider
giving him an epinephrine shot thinking
he is overdosed but luckily he wakes up
just before they can administer it
following this Tim confronts him about
the medicine and Daryl finally explains
the truth saying he only wanted to earn
some extra cash the following morning
Daryl goes to play the ice hockey match
for his college and everyone hopes that
he can win it for them like before
unfortunately his sensory condition
derails the game and Daryl cannot save
even a single shot as a result Stratford
ends up losing by a huge margin in the
next scene Daryl goes to a pub to find
Tim and asks for his help in preparing
for the final job interview to his good
luck Tim agrees system meanwhile Scott's
dad arranges for experienced advisors to
support him in answering interview
questions despite his health condition
getting worse Daryl remains determined
and focuses on studying hard to get
ready for the interviews on the day of
the interview Daryl steps out of his car
but his eyes become blurry making it
hard for him to see he asks a homeless
man for directions to the smith-based
corporation office unfortunately the man
takes advantage of Daryl's vulnerability
and leads him to a corner of the road
where he beats him up and robs him of
all his clothes leaving him naked Daryl
somehow manages to hide his private part
with a trash can lid and reaches a store
to get new clothes unfortunately upon
arriving at the office he realizes that
the dress he has selected is
inappropriate for the interview at the
same time the drug starts showing its
effects causing him to urinate in his
pants however after urinating Daryl
realizes that the drug has finally left
his system and he is totally back to
normal he then enters the competition
room defending his attire by saying that
he is allergic to formal clothing soon
the final round of interviews begins and
Daryl and Scott end up against each
other when faced with a tiebreaker
question from Professor angle Scott
fumbles with his response but Daryl
comes up with a brilliant answer this
impresses Tyson and he offers Daryl the
job however our boy feels guilty about
cheating with the drug so he comes clean
about his actions on stage despite the
shocking Revelation Tyson respects his
honesty and offers him a junior level
job at the company fast forward to a
year later we see Daryl as a junior
analyst entering the smith-based
corporation building to start his dream
job the movie ends with a heartwarming
scene revealing that Daryl and Janice
have gotten married and are moving into
a new house with their family subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching